Hello Freak bitches.
It makes you really like,
just like the way people are abused in other places and the way they don't have
rights of life.
The value a lot there.
If you're abused,
you know,
and you're just taken advantage of by whatever the government,
the local city,
you're just the situation,
your plight in the world.
I don't think that,
you know,
people say,
well there's no value of life.
And
I understand,
you know,
the,
they,
I watched one time a guy didn't want to spend
40 bucks to keep his kid alive and let him die.
He said he'd already spent a hundred and that was enough.
Okay.
You're getting into real situations,
Joe,
like that.
You see different ways people look at it and Christ and so now look,
is this every person there?
No,
but that's situations that happen.
Those are choices they had to make.
Wow.
And so yeah,
like absolutely.
It makes me appreciate America.
It makes me appreciate our bill of rights and makes me appreciate our political
system.
Makes me appreciate,
you know,
we've,
we pitch about things here that
the other world would die to have as a complaint.
You know,
we're upset,
the traffic's bad.
We're upset that,
you know,
my wife is mad at me that I'd come home at five 30 and I said,
I'll be all right.
No cannibals.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
people are upset about,
this transgender situation.
I mean,
Dude,
who cares?
You get to go home and hug your kid and you got a whole,
the world's biggest army dying for your rights,
dying for you.
You have a giant system that's protecting your life.
You have people dying for you every day.
There's one way to look at it.
Another way to look at it,
people would say is that giant system is set up by the military industrial
complex to steal resources was another country.
Okay.
That's why everybody's coming over here,
right?
They are.
It's the best.
Yeah.
For sure.
This is the best possible situation in the camera,
but it doesn't mean you and I are on a boat to get to that better live.
Well,
we know that it can be better.
I mean,
that's what I think what the argument is.
The argument isn't,
we should stop complaining.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I'm not saying we know it can get better,
but I'm just saying when you see it right,
it's far better than New Guinea.
It's far better than Somalia.
It's far better than a lot of the places you've traveled to.
Yes,
absolutely.
When you,
when you do travel to these places and you do go over there and you experience
their life,
does it give you this feeling of like,
like almost like helplessness.
Like you can't,
you can't do enough to help these people.
The system that they're involved in the life that they lived in the community
and there we sort of entangled in.
I can tell you,
Hans,
I've gone on with my dad and he brought it 20 full giant Cabella's bags,
just worth of gifts for him.
You know,
just given stuff at the very,
we,
my dad's name,
Larry,
we called it Larry Mart.
We just let them all come in and just pick everything they want,
you know,
and giving them things to hunt with.
No,
just soccer balls,
frisbees,
close toothbrushes,
anything,
you know,
and these are people that like need it.
And that's what a show like that covers Gilligan's island,
you know,
although no one fucked ginger or Maryanne,
there's no,
no one fucked at all.
If you want to talk about like one of the most unrealistic shows of all time,
Gilligan's island had to be because there was no sex,
there was no Saxon.
And yet how old are they?
They're basic human needs are pretty well met because the professor belt,
these kickass hots,
anal lagoons,
stuffed with fish.
Now he was like,
they were in Eden,
so they had plenty.
It's not like they didn't have time to hit on ginger,
make her a fucking,
make her a necklace out of some coral.
And they were always trying to leave and go back to civilization.
And all the people in civilization would watch that show go,
dude,
you're in paradise.
This girl can't do any better than you cause there's no one else.
Right.
You're trapped with like the hottest woman on the world.
The movie star,
the professor and Marianne.
Hey Ron gala
and the private professor wasn't a bad looking dude with a handsome bastards
smart shop at either one of those checks.
She wasn't.
She was an animal.
Good Lord God,
look how fat.
Hot Shit.
She's skimpy outfits too,
didn't she?
Of course she did.
I love how sh they pretended she had like Cheetah skin outfits on.
Yeah.
Where are you killing the Cheetah?
Did you skin that Cheetah?
Like how the fuck did you make the they really Marianne now too,
but they kept right.
She good body.
Fuck.
I thought Marion was hot.
Er.
I agree.
She's more of my tech.
Yeah,
I mean the,
the ginger.
She just seemed like she needed a lot of work.
Look how hot Marianne is to see that Maryann was not the hot one.
What the fuck man?
Really?
How's that Pos Marianne is hot as fuck dude.
Yeah,
she is injured.
Just slightly different.
Just ginger's trying too hard,
right?
Marianne's got a straw hat on Marianne is she's the girl in the bar and given
out hand jobs.
No,
no,
no.
You're married your bro.
What the fuck?
Now you married Mrs Howl.
You gotta bring her a lot of jewelry,
but you merrier.
Okay.
Oh,
look at them.
Look at Maryanne's body in that.
Holy Shit.
She had that seventies body to a little wider in the hips.
Little thick at the top of the leg,
but the flat ass Peli with the recess belly button.
Oh my God.
Any shots of the feet?
Gulak yet?
That old school foot fetish.
Oh,
they weren't high heeled shoes on a rowboat.
I hope they made the money.
So does he find out?
Did it make sure they did not?
They did not.
That was a long time ago.
Probably sign pictures at conventions and shit.
Wow.
Because none of them worked again.
Poor girl.
I don't remember ever seeing any of them in anything else.
No.
I'm Gilligan.
He would do like these.
I would loved both shins.
They would do these fan experiences.
They'd paid to take photos with them and had a fan of that.
I don't know if he did that,
but a lot of like lot of stars one up doing that.
They do autograph signings.
They get,
what's the range of conversations you have at that here you'd be,
you'd be Gilligan.
That'd be a fan that's coming up.
People in the line and then like every conversation is rushed,
right?
Because there's a bunch of people behind you.
Yeah.
Hey,
I love too is Gilligan.
Thank you.
Move along please.
Was there,
did you guys really go to an island for that?
Um,
I'm sorry sir.
If you want to,
uh,
answer questions across more.
And what about afterwards?
Ginger,
Maryann,
hire just one more thing.
You can't say that.
Why not?
Because we're at a signing.
He just broke my Maryanne.
Maryanne.
Thank you.
Here's $20 for the bad conversation.
What was the story that you told on Dom Herrera's podcast?
Oh,
Joe Walsh.
Bill Walsh.
Unbelievable story.
Joe Walsh is first of all,
an absolute king.
Like,
let me tell you,
he's one of the nicest guys I've ever opened for.
Uh,
he's like so cool.
You think it'd be Joe Walsh?
Like,
Hey,
I'm in the eagles.
Who the fuck are those?
He,
it wasn't like that at all,
but we were eating a,
a deli tray and he comes into the dressing room and he says,
hey,
don't eat that shit.
And we were like,
what?
Why?
And he goes,
ah,
you,
you don't know what's in there man.
You know,
it's just a Shitty Deli tray.
Don't eat it.
He's all,
I got sick before.
And I was like,
oh,
really?
And he goes,
yeah,
let me tell you.
He goes,
after he was out of the eagles,
he had a real low spot where he is partying hard and canceling gigs all the
time.
So he cleaned up and uh,
Amanda said we're booking a tour,
but if you cancel one show,
all the shows will be gone.
So the first night of the tour,
he's backstage eaten on the Deli tray after sound check.
And about a couple of hours later he gets mad food poisoning and he starts just
shitting and shitting.
And he's like,
what am I going to cancel?
And the manager goes,
you cancel this Gig.
The entire tourist gone.
So they go to Kmart or whenever was open and they get the rubber fishing waders.
He puts him on the ones that go up to your tits.
They were like,
we river runs through it,
fly fishing.
He gets on stage and just start going at it.
Why are you shitting?
Like every couple,
like every few minutes.
Oh yes.
You know,
and he's shitting into rubber when?
When does,
then he said mid show.
He didn't expect this,
but the heat from the lamp started burning the,
the diarrhea acid on his legs.
And as I looked at Joe Walsh,
we're wearing those cause he wore weird shit all the time.
It was a wacky show.
Denied shitting himself with weirs on first for him though.
First Minute I met him.
That's the story he told me and I hope it's true.
It's so great.
It's amazing.
What a great story you're talking about the eagles,
man.